you know what I mean like if you live
elsewhere it's the house pricing is
reasonable everything I was like that's
why you can't pop out like kids and be
more family oriented outside and working
on a new show where you're always
reading the News
That's depressing isn't it you want to
bring your kid into this but then yeah
he's always talking about the Japanese
birth rate needs help but he's not
having kids I probably have to go and
find some Japanese girls
[Music]
laughs
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of careful boys today we have
Ellen Kim with us
[Applause]
and we also have Christian Farina over
there
also we have Chris Sosa
who will be moving to New York soon so
we're not going to see him as often
and I'll be back I'll be back
they got pizza
they got pies we got a couple sbaros
something to the water man The Bagel so
different
succot something about the bagels man
all right check this out so in our
parents Generation all of us would be
pretty geriatric you know what I mean
like we would already be having like
five kids we're all coal miners and [ __ ]
deep into our careers we probably look
way older than we at actually are right
that's their generation right
um but now we're all like pushing that
like a like we're preserving that youth
a lot a lot longer right the only person
in here
um that got a kid is Ellen right good
job
sometimes my question is my question is
all right so do you see having kids
as like because Chris mentioned earlier
that's it his mom said when you have
kids your life is [ __ ] over done
straight up said that and do you think
do you think society today is putting
that [ __ ] off for as long as possible
because of those reasons because our
generation is the birth rate's lower
we're not having as much kids as our
parents generation and our grandparents
generation and on top of that if you
live in a big city you're getting
married later or not at all and you
don't [ __ ] have kids
so I guess it depends huh well Korea
they said that they're gonna go extinct
same with Japan Korea has the same
problem
because I mean look at the economy
everyone's you know like it's it's
different there like it's it's more
about career
and you need a high y'all can't go
extinct salary to have a kid I don't no
more K-pop and no more anime what are we
gonna do
that's a good point though is it the
money thing and also stress like I'm
meeting so many women right now who have
to go to IVF uh they have to do that
because they can't get pregnant and but
then those women are probably in their
30s right hitting 40s right so so that's
another thing too is that women are
trying to get pregnant much later on in
life but they're not told that after 30
you're um you're saying your eggs are
already like 75 done not even that it's
the stress look as a mom right and I was
a singer like a single mom and then you
know how were you when you had your baby
no but that's an average age average age
but then at that time it was like your
career is [ __ ] over you know and like
people saying that [ __ ] everyone like
dancers were saying it like I said that
sir
I was like I don't think so but like the
industry was like you're done like it
wasn't
my time it wasn't like you're not
supposed to have a kid and then like
even for family they're like your career
is going to be done because obviously
and look at you now prove them all wrong
and it's done but
even as a mom how much money you have to
make to make to get your kid education
make sure you're living in like a space
where you feel safe especially if you
are a single mom I had to move over to
Sherman Oaks because it's just me and
her right so that's what they don't tell
you in America is Affordable means
dangerous what do you mean oh yeah okay
like affordable rent and like paying
less in La that means you're [ __ ] in
a war zone yeah and then you gotta pay
for that that local so you're paying
premium for not to get robbed and then
the school system like if you're not
trying to pick oh my gosh I looked at
one private school here in La it's 33k
for kindergarten kindergarten
kindergarten that's somebody's [ __ ]
job dude so it's like you start learning
as a mom like you're like oh [ __ ] I
really gotta relocate because of the
education the safety then you're like
working how many jobs to sustain that
life you know and then of course like
woman today it's not like it's not
tribal anymore you're not gonna go
someone's gonna go grab the meat and the
you know someone else is going to attend
it together
everyone's hunting everyone's Gathering
so woman with the stress on top of
caught like you know hustle culture yeah
it's so hard it is hard because
everything used to be in teams back in
the day villages
because like you I remember like in our
parents generation right like if you're
a part of a church or whatever
um there were so many people that would
just meet up and like all the kids
kind of took care of each other and then
the parents had time to kind of chill
and do other errands and stuff so there
was that Community aspect but I do see
now a lot more single parents a lot more
like parents with just one or two kids
and they're doing everything there's no
grandma grandpa all that stuff so I'm
like how yeah so like this generation
right especially like in a city like LA
or whatever by I mean back in the day if
you're already like 20 something you're
already married and popping out kids but
now that's like it seems like almost
impossible you mean I'm most women I
talk to they're like
they don't want kids or they're going to
think about having kids around like
40. wow are they like freezing eggs
maybe freezing as if they have money but
it's so expensive to do this so
expensive but you also don't want to
like there's people that want kids but
you don't want to have a kid if you
can't support them and raise them right
I feel like it's just everything
combined with culture and society and
the way things are like inflation prices
like you said more people are single
doing their own thing
um it's tough It's hard to take care of
yourself before you take care of another
humans that's the hard part yeah here's
the thing as a mom I'm just gonna throw
it out there I thought the same thing
right everyone's already telling me okay
so then I have the kid and I'm like so
afraid I'm like I don't know but then
like
seeing her looking at me and I'm looking
at her I'm like oh [ __ ] I I need to do
this there's no option there's no other
option yeah you're turning to an animal
almost I started turning into like rare
like like
animals
oh my God
so do you think it made you more of a
hustler it made me more responsible oh
it made me like get my [ __ ] together and
like if and then find Value in my life
because of her and then it switched who
I was who I who I was like yeah I always
was like a people pleaser always working
for the industry oh you want me to cut
my hair like this but you know like but
when I had Kaya
it was like you know what I don't even
have [ __ ] time for that I don't got
time for that [ __ ] like look I need
to get a job this this I need to get her
education so I know society says it's
hard to have a child though it flipped
for me it made me a better person
because someone's mirroring me all the
time like if she says something weird
and I'm like that's on me like what am I
doing in front of you that you're acting
this way so like she made me
like I always tell her like you saved my
life like you really did because if I
kept going in the industry the way it
was going
I don't know who I would be today how
was it going like right when you had
your [ __ ] it was going good though
but you ruined my career well
if I'm talking like just super
narcissistic wise like Just Me Myself
and I yeah it was so great right like
six pack you know I was like booking
[ __ ] and you know whatever
but then it's like I meet people now and
they're like
I've gotten this couple times I'm like
oh [ __ ] they're like Ellen I just want
to say like
you're kind of a [ __ ] back then but
you're like really nice and I'm like oh
[ __ ] was I you know like was I going
down that path I said that to her
you could just start saying it to him
yes no but like you're probably just so
honest when you're single and selfish
and going for your career but I think
that is I mean
like if I had a kid right now yeah I
don't I don't want one right now because
of the things that we talked about yeah
watch this
um no because of like the financial
situation the way life is but like if I
had a kid I know it would be fine like
there's that mother
and a lot of women do believe like I
know some people where their purpose is
just to have kids and like you know
procreate and support that but also in
this generation now we have different
we're very
entrepreneurs you know going for our
dreams just with the access that we have
so I think there's like that cultural
Dynamic
um that's true because some girls it
seems like they get looked down upon for
wanting to be mothers and in some girls
it's like it's like um you have to be
CEO you have to do that and it's like
why can't people just choose what they
want that's what I'm saying being a mom
helped me get to that path though yeah
that's that's interesting because can I
tell you my [ __ ] perspective
from your life like you need to hear it
but like
can I judge you for a minute like but
just judge harsh okay because like I've
known for for a while and um I I feel
like I was kind of in the same boat as
you before you had your kid like we were
just trying to get whatever came and
we're just trying to book everything
right but I feel like after you had your
kid I didn't really feel like you fell
off at all but I felt like you
transitioned more into being like a boss
type figure I agree I saw that too even
more things that you were the Catalyst
for like you started doing your own [ __ ]
more it looked like where you were
booking people to be in your [ __ ] oh
that's what it looked like to me because
I'm like oh Ellen's like doing her thing
and you're the leader of more [ __ ] which
is like is that because having a kid
changed your look on like what how to
how to live your career
yeah thank you that's so sweet that's
what I thought thanks everyone
because like everyone wants to be that
right we all want to be like we all want
to go from trying to get jobs to being
the one at the head of the job and
people that want to work for us you know
what I mean that switch was I'm not
[ __ ] waiting for you to give me a job
I'm gonna make this job happen yeah and
then it and then I'm glad that like I
care about like people because it's like
because I want to do it with friends and
I wanted like I want you to get paid I
want and I want us to have fun with this
so you know what [ __ ] I'm gonna make
that [ __ ] happen yeah so yeah I don't
know uh yeah so then in some cases like
if you're if you're single and you think
about a kid you go oh then I'm not going
to be able to go out or do these
auditions or whatever but then when you
actually have one then that's the drive
for me makes you go I gotta get my [ __ ]
together yeah because I have this little
kid looking at me and I'm like you know
God made kids cute because if they
weren't like
drive you crazy you know what I'm saying
like so I got I got to witness that
firsthand uh through my little sister
she she had a child at a 20. and she's
the baby sister and everybody's like
whoa like it was like a surprise and
stuff and uh yeah like you know we all
we all got her back but at the end of
the day she has to raise a child and um
she's uh she's a powerful woman yo and I
got to like really like witness that you
know I mean my my nephew just turned
four uh um recently on the 13th and um
yeah you know I could see like all the
happiness and joy in her all of her uh
like she works really hard like she owns
her own house yo she's like she's the
house owner here we go yes a house under
owner she drives like 18 wheelers like
she's a super like she's a super mom yo
damn yeah yo so I really got to see that
you know and uh um like just hella proud
of her you know I mean like I'm like
yeah because I know like with my sister
like she has you know she's the younger
sister so she was able to see me and my
older brother like and see like how uh
you know what to do what not to do and
kind of follow what you know footsteps
whatever but she already has that grind
but now you have a child like you said
it times tends it you know what I mean
yeah it makes you step up yeah it makes
you step up you know what I mean and so
she put basically put the powers that
she already has and to now you know
raising a child and you can see that
through the child like the child's
amazing you know what I mean and that's
a reflection of how she is as a parent
you know what I mean so good [ __ ] me I'm
proud of you yeah that [ __ ] is so cool
there's like it's kind of scary too when
you see examples of like that's the best
case scenario that something like that
make you step up but we see people not
Step Up see that's the other side of it
too some people don't step up and they
can't support their kid kind of similar
situation with my sister she got
accidentally pregnant super young I
think she was 19 or 20 and she was kind
of going down a rough path
um but having the child like completely
changed her and the same thing has a
house family cars like like you figure
it out but then there's people on the
other side of it that that doesn't
happen they have a kid and they stay
lazy reason they don't get that fight
mode and then that kid suffers because
of it so or they get a flight mode
man I'm learning I'm learning like how
to like because the way that she's like
talked like communicating with her child
and how she like breaks everything down
and you know no really no whoopings yo
it's just all conversations like Are You
Gonna Keep crying okay do you go to the
room and cry when you come out we can
talk about it you know those type of
things I'm like damn like witnessing my
sister really break these things down
and like I'm like I don't know where she
gets it from but it's just it's that
instinct you know what I mean of just
knowing like you have no idea when you
have a child but then you figure it out
you know what I mean if yes because I
feel like this generation is the one
that's gonna really communicate to their
children yeah a lot of people are
parenting differently yeah it's very I
give her choices like I I tell her the
hard truth of what certain things are
like just for example sugar I showed her
a video of like what sugar does at a
very young age and she started crying
and I was like but this is like it's
diabetes
losing a tall yeah like here you go I
started crying but
I was like this is real life girl like
I'm not gonna paint this Disney [ __ ] to
you this is real life you want sugar you
choose yeah and then she took it and so
till today she'll be like I'm good like
yeah she's gonna moderate herself now
she's got her own choices
one of the things my aunt said that
she's like I didn't I didn't eat that
much meat growing up and I'm like why he
goes oh cause we just had to kill all
the animals that we wanted to eat so
then it was kind of a lot of work and
then it's dirty and so you have to kill
the chicken and all that and I'm all
like oh damn so if everyone had to kill
their own meat a lot of people would not
eat meat yeah there's a lot of dirty
work for sure yeah and then yeah they
saw death like to them it wasn't like a
like a once in a great like she was like
the reason why we had a lot of kids back
in the days because she's like they
won't all survive which one's gonna make
it yeah she goes that's why we had a lot
of brothers and sisters because one
might get the [ __ ] typhoid fever or
whatever you know one might get on the
Oregon Trail yeah after the axle breaks
somebody's gonna die you know yeah and
then so they had siblings die whatever
and then so they're like yeah that's why
we we popped out so many kids and then
so she's like yeah and it was like you
see death like and then people go to war
they don't come back I didn't [ __ ] like
that's another thing too is war yeah so
then I think like our generation is like
we think we are mortal
yeah yeah we were kind of and we think
we have forever to like pop out kids and
all that stuff and I was like that's
something that I didn't really think
about until like recently I'm like yo
I'm almost 40. and that's something
that's like by this age my dad already
had a couple
yeah I think about that too yo I'm 29 my
dad had three kids or at that by that
point yeah me thinking like I was
coherent enough to know when my parents
were 40. you know what I mean like I
remember them after
the kids are like how old are your
parents I'm like 45. you know what I
mean but yeah I don't know it's crazy it
trips it makes me sad because I I was
thinking about how I remember when my
dad turned 40 and I was already like
sentient I was like six or something and
I was making like he would always be
like hey come here and like pull my gray
hairs out man if you see any gray hairs
like pull them out for me and I remember
being old enough to be like damn good
right here's already gold yeah I don't
even have a kid yet and I'm like older
than he was in that memory like I'm
older than the dude that I'm seeing in
that and this is kind of depressing but
if you think of it in the opposite
perspective of you know if people are
having kids later let's say when they're
40 you know there's some guys out there
at 45 yeah if he did he still have kids
yeah that they're 20 their parents are
already 60 65 like the the relationship
and the span that you have with your
parents decreases as well and then if
those kids way even longer like 35 to
have kids their parents might never meet
their grandkids so it's a it's an
interesting effect that it's gonna
happen should we like make babies
um
I'm trying to turn into a boss female
CEO soon really yeah that's one thing I
don't like about it is that the climate
created this fear of having kids that
might not necessarily be true
I think so I don't like that like I
think so I don't have a kid now on
purpose I did that like I purposely
thought I was not ready because of what
I've learned around me and it's not
necessarily fact it's not you better
call smack right now
I've seen my sister do it I see my
brother do it and they both have kids
around the same age and my I have an
older brother but I've seen them doing
it they make it seem cool I'm in the
group chat like it's me uh the siblings
and my and my my parents that we're all
in the group chat and it's always
pictures of the nephews and I'm like man
I don't get to post nothing like I don't
get to share just put some stock photos
that's the thing you
look one of those different articles is
a reason to not have kids if you really
read into it you're like oh that's bad
this is bad that's not good it's like
this is the world they're gonna come
into and just living in La I think the
the mentality here is so different
because like it's affordable outside you
know what I mean like if you live
elsewhere it's the house pricing is
reasonable everything else like that's
why you can pop out like kids and be
more family oriented outside of the you
know and working on a new show where
you're always reading the News
That's depressing isn't it
you want to bring your kid into this but
then yeah he's always talking about the
Japanese birth rate needs help but he's
not having kids oh I probably have to go
and find some Japanese girls
yeah it's definitely the basis for it is
a lot of fear I feel like and you know
Anthony do it but not it switched for me
now I'm kind of like
damn
[Music]
[Music]